this is how many tourists imagine
Majorca and this is how the islands
authorities want it to be perceived in
future stylish and classy from this
summer new laws are set to make that a
reality additional police officers are
on patrol near a canal at the end of
playa de palma beach misdemeanors
attract fines of up to 600 euros is not
possible drink that glass bottle glasses
or mass is not possible and this is a
lot is not possible ah el comportamiento
de muchos baristas many terrorists think
they can behave however they like just
because they're in another country but
that's not okay the beach is here for
everyone to enjoy not just tourists
comparte mucha gente no solo los
turistas the notorious sangria buckets
that were once consumed by hard-drinking
german tourists here are now banned
and you're no longer allowed to wear
swim attire in the side streets behind
the beach the restrictions are designed
to change the atmosphere I'm not it's
different there's a different feeling
especially here at the beach but it
doesn't affect the atmosphere that much
mind saying [ __ ] it's all fair but I my
resolve this bucket drinking it's just
the thing here I don't do it but I don't
see the harm I guess I haven't yet last
night the ground was covered in beer can
so it's a good thing we were here last
year the atmosphere was better yes there
was music alcohol buckets it's not the
same anymore server party seekers are
not the biggest source of income for New
Yorkers tourist industry and they give
the island a down market image el gasto
mediaportal esta en el destino saddle
tourists are spending less and less here
so get a theme plumber has gone downhill
as a tourist destination e we've been
considering for a long time how we can
reposition it and revamp it as a
destination destino para ser un destino
damask Elida these new improved beach
chairs cost three times the old price
they're a sign that things are changing
here during the day it has already
become quieter
but in the evening the party goes on in
a 10 are the new rules have put few
tourists off some 4 million Germans
still flock to the island every year but
seasonal workers say things have changed
visibly when it's easy as you come this
year you can see the differences the
people are older there are all these
rules and police walking up and down
it's ridiculous it's not what it used to
be but who cares it's just once a year
by this mine madam yaa party-loving
German holiday makers still find
everything they expect pop veteran pay
debacle have been revving up the guests
here for 15 years he says officials will
never succeed in turning playa de palma
up market converts from Yvonne your
friends of mine went to their usual
hotel suddenly there was Wi-Fi a
flat-screen TV a new bathroom but it
cost the same I haven't noticed any
luxury tourism here I don't see anyone
building a thinker the written glamorous
don't come here majorca is quite divided
playa de palma is a party beach just
like magaluf is for the English then
there's port Adriano and Puerto portals
that's where you get the wealthy
glamorous set water bottles were done
with the author shouldn't invite
implement the rich and discerning
hangout far from the party crowd a place
is like Palmas anima beach club it
boasts an international clientele and
laid-back atmosphere and no over crowded
beaches this is what the local
authorities want people to picture when
they think of Majorca the image will be
complemented by gourmet harborside
restaurants
several hotels are being upgraded to
four and five-star accommodation within
six years majorca could look totally
different the island is looking forward
to showing its 10 million annual
visitors it's classy aside